[موسيقى]
مشاهدينا اهلا وسهلا بكم هاجمت قوات
الاحتلال الاسرائيلي باحات المسجد الاقصى
وطاردت المصلين لاخراجهم منها وحراسه
الجماعه اليهوديه المتطرفه التي حاولت
الدخول الى الحرم القدسي لكنها فشلت في
ذلك وطوقت قوات الاحتلال جميع مداخل الحرم
لساعات ومنعت المسلمين من الدخول اليها
نتوقف كالعاده مع هذا الخبر لنناقش في
محورين اولا ما ابعاد تصاعد محاولات
الجماعات اليهوديه المتطرفه لاقتحام
المسجد الاقصى وعلاقه ذلك بتنام النشاط
الاستيطاني في القدس
المحتله
وما تاثير هذه التحركات الاسرائيليه على
محاولات السلام حول قضايا مفاوضات السلام
حول قضايا الحل النهائي وخيارات
الفلسطينيين في
مواجهتها اهلا بكم يربط الاسرائيليون
التوتر في محيط المسجد الاقصى المبارك
بفتره الاعياد اليهوديه وينفون صلتها
بالاتصالات السياسيه غير ان جهات فلسطينيه
وعربيه ترى في محاولات الجماعات اليهوديه
المتطرفه اقتحام الحرم القدسي جزء من مسعى
اسرائيلي لتقسيمه وتهويده ويشيرون الى
انها ليست بمعزل عن نشاط استيطاني تزايدت
وتيرته في القدس المحتله منذ استئناف
مفاوضات السلام الفلسطينيه الاسرائيليه في
يوليو الماضي برعايه امريكيه نشاط يستهدف
خلق واقع جديد يستبق اي نتائج او اي نتائج
يمكن ان تتمخض عنها هذه
المفاوضات التوتر والمواجهات العنيفه بين
الفلسطينيين المقدسيين والاسرائيليين التي
شهدها المسجد الاقصى المبارك ومحيطه
ترويان فصولا جديده من فصول الاحتلال
الاسرائيلي للاراضي الفلسطينيه سلطات
الاحتلال اغلقت مداخل المسجد امام
الفلسطينيين وحاولت بالقوه اخراج عشرات
المعتكفين منهم داخله لتمكين المستوطنين
اليهود من دخوله واداء طقوسهم التلموديه
في باحات الاقصى بمناسبه عيد العرش نقل عن
المدير العام للاوقاف الاسلاميه بالقدس
قوله ان ممارسات الشرطه ومجموعات
المستوطنين زاد من حده الاوضاع وان كان
الوضع برمته يطرح قضيه الاقصى والمحاولات
اليهوديه لتدنيس بشده حتى بعد مرور عيدهم
الراهن رئيسه اللجنه الداخليه بالكنيست
صبت المزيد من الزيت على النار حينما دعت
يوم الاثنين لتطبيق اتفاق الحرم
الابراهيمي بالخليل على الحرم القدسي
وتقسيمه بين اليهود والمسلمين اذا استمر
المسلمون فيما وصفته بالاخلال بالنظام
العام الرئيس الفلسطيني محمود عباس استنكر
في لقاءاته بنيويورك السياسات الاسرائيليه
على الارض والمعاناه التي تلحق بالقدس
والمقدسات والمقدسيين جراءها وقال ان
اسرائيل تخرب المحادثات الجاريه عبر و
ممارساتها هناك لكن تعويله في ذات الوقت
على هذه المحادثات رغم ما ذكره وفي غمره
ما تشهده القدس المحتله يطرح علامات
استفهام كثيره كان عضو في هيئه العمل
الاهلي والوطني المقدسيه قد تحدث مؤخرا عن
تصاعد النشاطات الاستيطانيه في المدينه
بشكل كبير منذ استئناف المفاوضات الاخيره
بين السلطه الفلسطينيه واسرائيل وقال ان
عمليات بناء المستوطنات فيها لم تعد سرا
الاحداث التي يشهدها المسجد الاقصى تاتي
قبل ايام فقط من الذكرى الثالثه عش
لانتفاضه الاقصى التي اندلعت احتجاجا على
دخول رئيس الوزراء الاسرائيلي السابق
ارييل شارون الى باحه المسجد برفقه حراسه
حينها كان تصدي المصلين لموكبه هو شراره
الانتفاضه التي هزت الاسرائيليين بتصاعد
وتيره المقاومه الفلسطينيه بمختلف اشكالها
ولم تتوقف الا بعد نحو خمس
سنوات ومناقشه هذا الموضوع اذا معنا من
القدس الون استاذ العلاقات الدوليه في
الجامعه العبريه والمدير السابق لوزاره
الخارجيه
الاسرائيليه ينضم الينا ايضا من رام الله
دكتور مصطفى البرغوثي الامين العام
للمبادره الوطنيه
الفلسطينيه وينضم الينا ايضا من رام الله
الدكتور عبد الله عبد الله القيادي في
حركه فتح ورئيس اللجنه السياسيه في المجلس
التشريعي الفلسطيني عن الحركه نرحب
بضيوفنا جميعا وابدا معك دكتور عبد الله
عبد الله دعنا نفهم في البدايه مع
المشاهدين نحاول ان نفهم ما الذي يجري في
الاقصى هذه الايام ما ابعد تصاعد محاولات
الجماعات اليهوديه المتطرفه لاقتحام
المسجد
الاقصى هنالك مخططات اسرائيليه منذ
الاحتلال الاسرائيلي في العام 67 وهي تسعى
لتغير
هويه الاراضي الفلسطينيه وتحديدا مدينه
القدس تغيير الهويه
يستدعي ثلاث عوامل العامل الاول هو انقاص
الحضور الفلسطيني البشري في هذه المدينه
وهنالك برامج وضعت منذ ذلك التاريخ لانقاص
العدد الفلسطينيين ليصل الى 12% من مجموع
السكان ولكن هذه المحاولات فشلت لان
الفلسطينيين بدل ان تنقص نسبه حضورهم في
القدس
كانت 34 الان صارت 37% ا ولكن محاولات
اسرائيل لم تتوقف تحاول ان تعدل ذلك
بالاستيطان تحاول ان تعدل ذلك من التضييق
على حياه الفلسطينيين اقتصاديا سكنيا
تعليميا وصحيا لتفرض نوع من الهجره
القصريه على الفلسطينيين حتى تتغير طبيعه
التركيبه الديموغرافيه في القدس الجانب
الاخر الجانب الديني نعم تفضل تفضل ماذا
عن الجانب الديني
باختصار عن الجانب الديني ال القدس معروفه
في العالم بهويتها الاسلاميه المسيحيه
فيها مسجد الاقصى المبارك وفيها كنيسه
القيامه والصور التي كانت تنشر للقدس حتى
في الادله السياحيين كانوا يبرزون هذين
المعلمين ال اسرائيل تريد ان تطمس هذين
المعلمين هي تضغط على على ان يقل الحضور
المسيحي في القدس بحيث تكون كنيسه القيامه
مجرد مزار هي تضغط الان على الحضور
الفلسطين الاسلامي في القدس ليصبح ايض كما
ذكرت نعم لنفهم من الاستاذ الون لي لماذا
تفعل اسرائيل او الجماعات اليهوديه
المتطرفه التي حاولت اقتحام الحرم القدسي
الشريف في ظل حراسه قوات الامن
الاسرائيليه لماذا تفعل
ذلك
انا اجلس في استوديو هنا في القدس ليس
بعيدا عن
الاقصى ولكنني لا اعلم اي شيء عما يجري
الان او اليوم بشكل عام عما قاله صديقي
عبد الله عبد الله اعلق قائلا بعض ما قاله
صحيح واسرائيل
تتبنى سياسه المست
وتوسيع المستوطنات في القدس والاسرائيليون
مازالوا يبنون في
القدس ليس كلنا في اسرائيل نحب ذلك ولكن
هذه سياسه حكوميه وعلى الارجح ليس من قبل
هذه الحكومه ولكن من حكومات اخرى بشكل
واضح وهنا نتحدث عن العامل الديموغرافي
والديني وهذا
الكفاح المنضوي في الكفاح من اجل مستقبل
فلسطين او القدس ولهذا السبب نحن نجلس
الان نتحدث عن مستقبل
البلدين
وعن الجانبين للقدس وانا امل حقا لشيء ان
يتمخض عن هذه المحادثات الجاريه الان ولا
اشعر بالتفاؤل رغم ذلك ولكن طالما انها
تستمر وطالما ان هناك دعم قوي امريكي لهذه
المحادثات
ا يعني هذه الاجواء مساعده لهذه
المفاوضات
واضح بانه انما صح هذا وان كان هناك عنف
بالفعل في الاقصى وفي
القدس رغم انني لم اسمع به شخصيا و في
القدس
الاخبار في اسرائيل
التي سمعتها تتحدث عن ما يجري في كينيا
وليس في القدس نعم رغم ان المسافه استاذ
الوني المسافه بين المكتب الذي تجلس
لتحدثنا وتحدثنا منه ليست بعيده كثيرا عن
الاقصى ربما الدكتور مصطفى البرغوثي من
رام الله يتابع الاوضاع عن عن
كتب اكثر منك دعنا نفهم منه دلالات توقيت
ما يحدث قبل ثلاثه ايام من ذكرى اندلاع
انتفاضه الاقصى في ال8 من سبتمبر ما الذي
ما اسبب ما يحدث ما ما المغزى من
ذلك شكرا لك ودعيني اولا اوجه التحيه
لشباب القدس وشابات القدس
ولاهل رجالا ونساء وخاصه نساء القدس على
الوقفه البطوليه الرائعه التي وقفوها امس
ووقفو اليوم في وجه قطعان المستوطنين وجيش
الاحتلال دفاعا عن الاقصى ودفاعا عن عروبه
القدس ودفاعا عن المقدسات الاسلاميه
والمسيحيه انا استغرب ان بعض الاسرائيليين
لا يعرفوا ما يجري ولكن الواقع ان ما يجري
خطير جدا نحن نتحدث عن عمليه مخططه ومبرم
ويجري تنفيذها منذ اكثر من 40 عاما عندما
تم احراق المسجد الاقصى قصدا وعمدا على
امل ازالته وفشلوا في ذلك ومنذ ذلك الحين
تتوالى عمليات الضم والتهويد والتوسع
الاستيطاني الذي يجري اليوم في الاقصى
بالتحديد امر خطير لانه يستهدف فرض وجود
يهودي داخل المسجد الاقصى الاحد اهم واقدس
الاماكن المقدسه لدى المسلمين يريد ان
يقسموا المسجد الاقصى زمنيا وبعد ذلك
مكانيا بحيث حث يقسم بين اليهود والمسلمين
كما فعلوا بالحرم الابراهيمي في الخليل
دون اي احترام للمشاعر والمعتقدات الدينيه
او لحقوق الشعب الفلسطيني في المدينه
المقدسه ثانيا الذي يجري امر خطير لانه
يدخل في سياق عمليه تهويد القدس
نفسها المسجد الاقصى كما نعلم يشكل حوالي
سدس مساحه البلده القديمه الفلسطينيه في
المقدسيه وهم يحاولوا من خلال الاستيلاء
على هذا الجزء او على جزء منه ان ي ان ان
يقوموا بعمليه التهويد للمدينه المقدسه
بكاملها ويبد انهم حصلوا على كفه اللازمه
لذلك نعم والامر الاهم والاخطر ان ذلك
يجري في ظل المفاوضات وبرايي انا ان
المفاوضات لن تؤدي الى شيء بالعكس اليوم
يتضح كل صحه كل ما حذرنا منه عندما عرضنا
هذه المفاوضات لانها تستخدم كغطاء لعمليه
التوسع الاستيطاني وانا اعتقد ان هناك
عمليه منهجيه خطيره تقوم بها اسرائيل ومن
يدعم اسرائيل لكي الوعي الفلسطيني والعربي
والاسلامي والمسيحي للقبول بالامر الواقع
امر واقع جديد يج يتم فيه تهويد المسجد
الاقصى وتهويد القدس برمتها عمليه كي
الوعي تشمل القدس وتشمل الاغوار وتشمل فرض
اشياء على الفلسطينيين لم يقبلوها في عام
2000 عندما عرض الرئيس الامريكي كلينتون
تقسيم المسجد الاقصى الى فوق الارض
للمسلمين وتحت الارض لليهود ورفض ذلك
الرئيس الراحل ياسر عرفات وادى ذلك الى
الانتفاضه الثانيه كما نعلم الذي يجري
اليوم هي محاوله لكي الوعي كي يقبل
الفلسطينيون بما رفضوه في السابق وهذا امر
خطير جدا هذا بالاضافه الى ان ما يجري هو
اعمال استفزازيه تجري بقرارات من الحكومه
الاسرائيليه نتنياهو الذي لم يعبا
باستشهاد سبع فلسطينيين خلال فتره
المفاوضات كان حياه الفلسطينيين لا تهم
احدا لان احد الجنود قتلوا في الخليل اعلن
عن عمليه ضم غير القانونيه حتى بالقانون
الاسرائيلي لبنايات في مدينه الخليل وقال
بكلام واضح
انا سنحارب الفلسطينيين باليد اليمنى
ونوسع الاستيطان باليد اليسرى وكما قال
احد المعلقين فباي يد سيصنع السلام الذي
يجري عمليات استفزاز مقصوده وخطيره لتدمير
مستقبل هذه المنطقه وتهويد القدس طيب دعني
انقل هذا الكلام الى الون ليل قبل ان اعود
الى الدكتور عبد الله عبد الله لماذا ايضا
استباق مفاوضات ال الوضع النهائي بفرض هذا
الواقع
كامر يعني هذا الامر كواقع بالنسبه
للفلسطينيين اعتقد ان من المحزن ان نرى
سياسيين خبيرين فلسطينيين كمصطفى البرغوثي
وعبد الله عبد الله يحاولان ان يثير
را المشاعر بدلا من ان يقولوا
للفلسطينيين ولشعوب العالم كلها الذي التي
تشاهد الجزيره بان هناك الان
جهدا مدعوما بقوه من قبل اوباما بغيه خلق
دولتين لشعبين واحد واحده للاسرائيليين
وواحده للفلسطينيين هذا هو جوهر الكفاح
وليس ما يجري يوميا في الشارع اقول خلال
الايام الاخيره جنديان اسرائيليان قتلا
اذا فالعمل لا نهايه لها ولكن اقول ان
الخبراء مثلنا بعقود من العمل والخبره
لدعم السلام من قبل الجانبين يجب ان
يحاولوا ان يضعوا جانبا باقصى قدر
ممكن الكفاح والقتل ورمي الحجاره جانبا
ويركز على المح
دعونا نرى ما الذي يجري في المحادثات
لماذا ليس هناك تقدم في المحادثات بالامس
اوباما قال
ثانيه انه يريد حدود ب 67 بعمليه تبادل
لماذا لا نسمع اي شيء انبثق عن المحادثات
لماذا لا يقوم الامريكان بالحديث عن هذه
المحادثات اعتقد ان هذا هو الامر الذي يجب
ان نركز عليه اولا واخرا طيب سنتحدث عن
المفاوضات بعد فاصل قصير
سنناقش تاثير هذه التحركات الاسرائيليه في
القدس على مفاوضات السلام حول قضايا الوضع
او الحل النهائي فلا تذهبوا
[موسيقى]
بعيدا مشاهدينا اهلا وسهلا بكم من جديد
الى هذه الحلقه التي تناقش تصاعد محاولات
الجماعات اليهوديه المتطرفه لاقتحام الحرم
القدسي الشريف وتاثيرها على مفاوضات
السلام الف فلسطينيه الاسرائيليه دكتور
عبد الله عبد الله اذا نريد ان نفهم في
هذا الجزء الثاني من البرنامج تاثير ما
يحدث على مفاوضات السلام الفلسطينيه
الاسرائيليه ولا بد ان نشير هنا الى ان
الرئيس محمود عباس تعهد في نيويورك تعهد
للرئيس الامريكي باراك اوباما بان يبدل
الفلسطينيون كل جهد ممكن لضمان نجاح
المفاوضات
كيف المفاوضات ليست شيئا جديدا وكل نزاع
في العالم ان كان بين دولتين او اكثر لابد
في نتيجه الامر ان يحل بمفاوضات تحدد شروط
انهاء ذلك النزاع والقضيه الفلسطينيه ليست
شذوذا عن هذا الامر المفاوضات هي وسيله
ل سبر امكانيه التوصل الى الحل حسب
المعايير الدوليه حسب الحقوق الوطنيه التي
يتمسك بها الفلسطينيون مفاوضين وغير مفاوض
هذه الامور قد تنجح وقد تفشل لكن
المفاوضات بحد ذاتها لم تمنع الفلسطينيين
ان يواجهوا الاحتلال في القدس او في
قلنديا او في مخيم جنين او في اي بقعه من
بقع الاحتكاك الفلسطينيه نعم لكن دكتور
دكتور دكتور عبد الله المفاوضات يعني
السؤال جوهري هو انه لماذا بالاصل قبلتم
الدخول في مفاوضات في مقابل يعني المقابل
قليل وهو اطلاق عدد محدود اطلاق سراح عدد
محدود من الاص لا لا اسمحي لي تفضل اسمحي
لي لا هذا الموضوع ليس دقيقا يعني لست
دخولنا من اجل اطلاق هذا العدد المحدود من
الاسرى هذا العدد من الاسرى ال 104 لم يكن
نتيجه المفاوضات هذا في قرار باطلاق سراحه
منذ العام 99 والحكومه الاسرائيليه لم
تنفذ وكان هذا الاشتراط للتاكد من مدى
جديه الحكومه الاسرائيليه بالالتزام باي
ناتج عن هذه المفاوضات لكن مفاوضات دخلت
بمرجع واضحه وهي اقامه الدوله الفلسطينيه
على حدود العام 67 وعاصمه القدس وحل قضايا
الوضع النهائي السبعه القدس والحدود
واللاجئين والمياه والاسرى والامن و
و نعم تفضل يعني السبعه المعروفه يمكن
فهذه هي حدود احنا ما هو مطلوب من المفاوض
الفلسطيني مدى تمسكه بهذه الحدود
بهذه السقف الذي حدده له القياده السياسيه
الفلسطينيه لكن الاستيطان مستمر سواء في
مفاوضات او ما في مفاوضات والمحاولات
الاسرائيليه في تغيير الطابع الديمغرافي
والجغرافي للقدس ايضا مستمر ولكن المطلوب
كيف نواجه كل هذه المحاولات الاسرائيليه
حتى الان بالرغم من التحولات اللي نعيشها
في الاقليم او في العالم ربما سجلنا تقدم
على الساحه الدوليه اكبر او اكثر مما
سجلناه على الساحه الاقليميه لظروف
موضوعيه نحن لا يعني نعرفها وربما نتفهمها
ولكن هذه المعركه المستمره ما دام هنالك
احتلال هنالك مقاومه هذه المقاومه تاخذ
اشكالها المتعدده هذه المقاومه
ت
تتطلب توفير مقومات الصمود لو لم يكن
المقدسيون موجودون في داخل القدس لما
تصدوا
لقطعان سيد الون ليل يعني توسع استيطاني
محاولات تهويد القدس محاولات الاقتحام
الاقصى يعني تغيير هويه القدس وما الى ذلك
كل هذا وتقول اسرائيل مازالت جاده في
العمليه السياسيه وفي مفاوضات السلام مع
الفلسطينيين يعني كيف يمكن ان يقبل هذا
الكلام باي منطق
بالنسبه للحكومه الاسرائيليه والتي لا
امثلها ولكن اقول ان الحكومه الاسرائيليه
تقالت بانها تخوض المفاوضات وفي الوقت
ذاته توسعوا المستوطنات في القدس
والفلسطينيون لم يتوقفوا عن المحادثات فما
زالت مستمره ولا اعتقد ان هذا مساعد ولكنه
عامل قطع وتعطيل ولكن هذه هي نظره
الاغلبيه في الحكومه وفي الكنيست وهم
يدعمون ذلك واعتقد لان هذه حقيقه معروفه
لا يمكن تغييرها اعتقد ان الفلسطينيين
ينبغي ان يركزوا على قضايا اخرى على سبيل
المثال قبل بضعه ايام نائب وزير الدفاع
داني دانوب نشر مقالا في النيويورك تايمز
قائلا بانه لن يكون هناك دولتان فقط دوله
واحده فلسطينيون يجب ان يتساءلوا لماذا
هذا الرجل ما زال يعمل في الحكومه اذا ما
كان نتنياهو جديا في السير في حل الدولتين
يجب عليه ان يقيل هذا الرجل وينحي جانبا
والا فانه ليس جديا في عمله
لا اعتقد بان علينا الخوض في هذه القضايا
لان هناك اناس من الطرفين لا يريدون
المحادثات ويريدون تعطيل الم حادثات على
الارض كل يوم بكل ما بوسعهم ولكن
السياسيين على سبيل المثال مثل نائب
الوزير هذا لا يمكن ان يقول بانه ضد حل
الدولتين وان يبقى في الحكومه
ودون ان يكون هناك التزام بحل
الدولتين بينما
الامريكان يقولون بدون حل الدولتين لن
يكون هناك دوله اسرائيل ديمقراطيه يهوديه
هذه هي القضايا التي ينبغي للفلسطينيين ان
يركزوا عليها طيب هذا ما يجب ان يركزوا
عليه ولكن يعني هذا الكلام يسمعه
الفلسطينيون من سنوات ولكن
يعني نسمع جلبه ولا نرى طحينا هكذا ربما
يقول المثل الدكتور مصطفى البرغوثي
البدائل امام الشعب الفلسطيني اليوم ما
هي اولا انا اعتقد ان السيد الون ادان
نفسه بنفسه يعني هو يطالبنا بان نواصل
الحديث مع حكومه مستوطنين وفي نفس الوقت
يقول ان هذه الحكومه فيها متطرفين مثل
داني دانون ومستوطنين اخرين وهذا يعني شيء
متناقض بالمناسبه هو يقول اننا نلهب
المشاعر وانا اقول له بكل وضوح وصراحه نحن
لا نخفي ما ندعو اليه واعيد واكرر ما ندعو
اليه نحن ندعو الى تصعيد المقاومه الشعبيه
الفلسطينيه بكل اشكالها وباوع شكل ممكن ضد
الاحتلال والاستيطان لان هذا هو الطريق
الوحيد لتغيير ميزان القوى وليس عبر
مفاوضات فاشله وستبقى فاشله ثانيا نحن
ندعو الى مقاطعه وعقوبات ضد اسرائيل ونحقق
نجاحات كل يوم وانا احيي هنا ايضا حركه
المقاطعه وفرض العقوبات التي تتقدم الان
في كل انحاء العالم ويجب ان تعامل اسرائيل
كحكومة قوه ونحن ندعو ايضا الى وحده
الفلسطينيين ووحده موقفهم واعاده توحيد
موقفهم لانه الذهاب للمفاوضات مره اخرى
ودون التعلم من تجارب السابقه والمؤمن لا
يلدغ من جحر مرتين الذهاب الى مفاوضات دون
وقف الاستيطان ودون مرجعيه واضحه ازاد زاد
حاله الانقسام الموجوده في الساحه
الفلسطينيه الذي يجري امر خطير المفاوضات
تستخدم كغطاء لتوسع استيطاني ولعمل ضم
وتهويد نحن نناضل من اجل سلام عادل وليس
من اجل استسلام مهين ولكن الذي يجري على
ارض الواقع هو ليس انشاء دولتين وانما
دوله اسرائيل موجوده بكل مكوناتها والسلطه
الفلسطينيه تحول الى منظوم تحول الى
منظومه بانتو ستان وكنتو ومعاز في اطار
نظام ابارتهايد وفصل عنصري في خلال
المفاوضات اسرائيل افرجت عن 6 اسير
واعتقلت 300 اخرين جدد منذ تم الافراج
عنهم اسرائيل دمرت مناطق مثل خربه مكحول
في الاغوار وتهاجم قريه مثل قريوت وتقوم
بعمليه تطهير عرقي على الارض لفرض الامر
الواقع المفاوضات اصبحت غطاء للتوسع
الاستيطاني وبغض النظر عن ابتسامات السيد
اوباما او غير اوباما ما يهمنا هو ما يجري
على ارض الواقع نحن باعتقادنا اننا بحاجه
الى نهج بديل لهذه المفاوضات التي فشلت في
السابق وستبقى تفشل مادام مزان القوى
متغير غير لم يتغير لصالحنا البديل هو
استراتيجيه وطنيه موحده جديده تجمع ما بين
المقاومه والكفاح وفرض العقوبات على
اسرائيل وتوحيد الصف الوطني وايضا سياسات
اقتصاديه تدعم المزارع الفلسطيني وتدعم
الانسان الفلسطيني الصامد على ارض وطنه
وخاصه في مدينه القدس في مواجهه اسرائيل
شكرا شكرا لك دكتور مصطفى البرغوثي الامين
العام للمبادره الوطنيه الفلسطينيه كنت
معنا من رام الله ونشكر ايضا من القدس
الون ليل استاذ العلاقات الدوليه في
الجامعه العبريه والمدير السابق لوزاره
الخارجيه الاسرائيليه شكرا لك نشكر ايضا
الدكتور عبد الله عبد الله القياديه في
حركه فتح ورئيس اللجنه السياسيه في المجلس
التشريعي الفلسطيني عن الحركه شكرا لكم
جميعا وبهذا تنتهي مشاهدينا هذه الحلقه من
برنامج ما وراء الخبر نلتقي باذن الله في
قراءه جديده وما وراء خبر جديد اطيب المنى
والى
اللقاء
[موسيقى]
ا